we're going to move on now to california
where thousands of buildings and other
structures are threatened by the state's
largest wildfire this season the
mosquito fire so named for the ridge
where it started east of sacramento has
burned miles and miles of land more than
46 thousand acres in all and it is only
10 percent contained despite lower
temperatures over the weekend crews are
still struggling to bring the fire under
control and as mark straussman shows us
it is just one of more than a dozen
large fires in the american west
parts of northern california look
apocalyptic
dark columns of smoke reaching thousands
of feet in the air it's the mosquito
fire burning nearly out of control
firefighters are working very hard and
they've been fighting a lot of different
fires
all night they're working 24 hour shifts
rough terrain is only one challenge
among many extreme heat and dry
conditions over the past week have
spread flames faster and hotter at risk
firefighting crews and more than 11
thousand evacuees we don't know if we
even have a home
a rare rainy weekend in southern
california gave fire crews an unexpected
weapon in their battle with a fairview
fire it's now more than 40 percent
contained
in washington state the bolt creek fire
has already destroyed more than 7 500
acres since sparking saturday morning
and in oregon the cedar creek fire
exploded more than 85 thousand acres
blackened forcing evacuations and
leaving roughly 25 thousand people
without power
back in california evacuee donald garner
slept in his car hoping for a
breakthrough about all we could do just
hope and pray that everything goes okay
for everybody firefighters facing
another hairy week
agree
for cbs mornings mark strassman in los
angeles